c'est de plus en plus de voix s'élèvent
pour presser le gouvernement à mieux
soutenir les locataires
elle réclame un registre public des
loyers et un contrôle obligatoire des
reprises et des évictions de logements
mon fils de 21 ans que cherchait un
appartement puis rien en voie de 900000
1400 bien d'amour ça aucun sens il ne
devrait pas être une difficulté os
devrait pas être une bataille quand on
est enfant on devrait pas avoir à porter
c'est pour ces trucs là
vendredi soir des manifestants se sont
aussi rassemblés devant le manoir la
fontaine les locataires ont reçu un avis
d'évacuation temporaire de la part du
propriétaire qui invoque des travaux
majeurs
ils se disent victimes de rénovation le
comité de logement le constate le prix
des loyers explosent et les reprises de
logement sont plus fréquentes
cet ami ils doivent aider beaucoup plus
de gens qui al'habitude normalement
d'une centaine de demandes
d'informations sur des reprises ont des
évictions ondres traduit autour de 400
demandes d'information cette année
céline victime ni par exemple a fait
face à une reprise de logements cette
année elle a finalement eu gain de cause
je voyais toute ma vie s'écrouler ça
fait 24 ans que je suis dans ce logement
de paye pas trop chambre et là je
perdais mon voisinage avec qui je
m'entends bien
et je perdais trop tard de son côté la
ville de montréal interpelle aussi le
gouvernement provincial pour mieux
réglementer les loyers la ville explique
essayer d'augmenter l'offre de logement
social tout nouveau projet de
construction est obligatoire d'inclure
du logement social logement abordable ça
mais bon va falloir avoir aussi lisse ou
de québec pour les construit pour payer
cette partie là où cabinet de la
ministre des affaires municipales et de
l'habitation
on se dit sensible à la situation mais
on estime qu'un registre des loyers
entraînerait des coûts importants pour
tout le québec des provinces ont déjà
essayé pour finalement l'abandonner pour
des raisons d'efficacité et de coups ici
marc isabelle rochon radio canada
montréal
[Musique]